hi there I'm Marcus in this two-part
video series I will show you how to
build an application using web
components just using the plain vanilla
JavaScript API and then in the second
part of the video series I will show you
how to turn this plain web application
into a progressive web application so
let's get started here I have a just a
stub application we have a header with
some meta tags we have a body section
with a header we have a main section
where we'll we'll fill in these news
articles and we have an index file where
we're going to add our application
logics so to start off I will add a load
event listener on our window objects a
window to add eventlistener
load the reason I'm adding a load
listener here is that I don't want to
block the initial render with any
JavaScript so by delaying this until the
pages had a chance to load we can make
sure that the experience is smooth and
fast for our users
so once the window page is loaded we'll
call fetch news fetch news will be an
asynchronous function where we can call
the network and fetch those news
articles so I'll use an ASIC function
here call it touch news doesn't take
into any parameters what I want to do
here is first of all get the result of
fetching the top headlines I've
extracted these into a separate file
here so I can just import these into my
main file so I'll import from use API
dot jeaious I'm not running any kind of
bundling or anything here so I'll add
the jeaious extension so that the
browser is able to find this so I'll
fetch the top headlines URL I will then
fetch that from the network once that
comes in we want to extract the JSON
from that result so again we await
result the JSON so that will give us the
JSON response from the noose API the
second thing I need to do is get a hold
of this main section of my document so
just document query selector for the
main section and we'll extract this into
a constant main it's a good thing we
need to do then is take our JSON there's
an array of articles on it and for each
of those we will just create a new
component for it essentially a news
article per article so what I'll do here
is I'll call document.createelement and
we will create a new HTML element of
type news article well again
extract this to a constant it's called
element then on that element we will set
the article property on it to the
article from our array and then finally
we'll take our main and we'll end this
as a child to it like that okay so I
will now take run this application with
just a normal HTTP server and open it up
in the browser what we can see right now
is that we have these news article tags
in our HTML but we don't really have any
content because we haven't defined we
haven't told the browser how a newest
article should behave in order to define
a new HTML tag what I want to do is just
create a new file with the same name as
the SD HTML tag so news
article Jas and the actual definition of
a new HTML tag or a web component is two
steps so the first step is creating a
class news article and extending from
the HTML element class once we have the
actual implementation of our component
we need to register this with the
browser we do that by calling the custom
elements registries define method so
custom elements define we map it from a
tag name so our tag name is news article
and the implementation for this tag is
this news article class that we just
created okay so the only part of the or
the only API we have for this component
is that Center for the article where we
passed in the article here so we'll
implement this here set article takes in
the article and we'll just set the
interatrial in this case to to a
template string that just pulls in the
URL the title the image and the
description from that now that we have
the definition we'll go back to our main
file here we will import this file so
just do an import newest article is save
here and we'll go back to the browser
and refresh so you can see now that
those news articles are still here but
now they actually have some content to
them you can see that we have a bunch of
news here now one of the things that you
often hear talked about when people are
talking about web components is shadow
DOM shadow DOM is a feature the web
component specs where we are able to
encapsulate kind of hide the inner
details of a component if we want to use
shadow Dom in a component we'll create a
constructor for our component here
super so the HTML element gets to run it
set up first and then we'll create a new
shadow root first so we do this by
calling the stud attach shadow we need
to specify mode for it
so mode can be open or closed but you
should always select open here the way
we use this is instead of just setting
directly the inner HTML of our component
we'll set the inner HTML of our shadow
root instead so we just simply do it
best root inner HTML instead now if we
run this again we can see that it still
works but we lost all of our CSS Styles
the reason is because the shadow route
shadow Dom essentially shield stainer
implementation of this component from
any external CSS likewise any styles
that we define inside of our component
won't leak into the main document so
what we need to do is we need to
actually move in the styles into our
component itself so we'll add a style
tag here and then we'll copy over those
styles so have those right here copy
them over it's going to save that put
them in here since we are already inside
of this newest article tag we don't need
this extra selector here so just go
ahead and select those delete them save
it and go back to a browser check that
everything works as expected all right
so there we have it we have a
application built with web components
and just plain vanilla JavaScript what I
want to do now is turn this application
into a progressive web application what
I want to be able to do is install this
application on devices that support it
and have it run offline so that we can
see some previously fetched news even if
we are offline now when we're building a
progressive web application a
place to start is the application tab in
chrome dev tools it will essentially
guide you through the steps needed we'll
start up here at the manifest tab and
right now we can see that there's no
manifest detected so that's a good
indication of what we need to do first
so we'll jump into our code here and we
will create a new file a Ana fest web
any first the web manifest is just a
JSON file containing some of the basic
information about our application like
its name what URL should start some
basic things like icons as such once we
have the file itself will go into our
index file and we'll link to our
manifest so just the same way as we
would link to a stylesheet we will link
to our manifest file we'll save this go
back to our browser refresh and we
should be able to see that we have our
manifest file here so we can see our
icons we can see the name we can also
see that there's an add to homescreen
link here now so this is a good way for
us to check if our application is in
fact installable so let's click on it ok
so we can see that we can't install this
because there's no matching
serviceworker detected so that's again a
good indication on what we need to do
next so I'll create a new Service Worker
fall serviceworker jeaious if you're not
familiar with a serviceworker it's
essentially a JavaScript worker that
sits between your application and the
network this means that whenever your
application goes out to the network it
will pass through the serviceworker it
allow us to do things like caching in
between so we can decide ourselves
whether or not we actually want to go
out to the network for a particular
resource we can also decide that we can
return some things from our cache if we
are offline so this will allow us to
make our application work offline ok so
we have our serviceworker file the next
part of using a serviceworker is
registering it so we'll go into our load
listener here and once we've fetched
newse the user is already happily using
the application we can go ahead and
register our service worker call this
register SW so we'll implement this
service worker register the registration
looks something like this so we have a
quick feature detection first we want to
make sure that the browser actually does
support service worker before we try to
register it we then call service worker
dot register on the navigator object and
pass in our service worker file so let's
save this let's go back to our
application refresh and see if we got an
service worker it's a little bit smaller
so we can now see that we do in fact
have a service worker file while you're
developing it's really good to keep this
update on reload check that way you'll
get all the new changes that you make to
service work very visible immediately
instead of having to close the window
and reopen it which would normally be
required for a service worker to take
take effect so we'll go back and turn
the manifest file here our manifest tab
will click on that to hold screen and
see if we're there already turns out
we're still not able to install the
application because the browser is
telling us that the page doesn't work
offline now that makes sense because our
service worker file is completely empty
and the service worker is a completely
event-driven thing so it can only run
code if some event triggers that the
first event that gets triggered on a
service worker is the install event so
we'll add a listener for the install
event on the service worker itself
typically what we want to do in the
install event is cache some like static
files that we know our application will
need the way we do that is by using the
cache API so we'll open up a cache with
give a name and then we will add a list
of static assets that we have so let's
define our cash name first cash name
let's call this news v1 and then we'll
define an area of the different static
assets that we have so our index page
CSS and JavaScript files and so on we'll
save those the final thing that we do
here is we call skip weighting which
will cost the service worker to move
into the activate face the activate
faces essentially when a new service
worker takes over from any previous
service workers normally what you would
do here is clean out any previous
versions of your cache for instance what
I'm calling here is self dot clients
that claim which will essentially tell
my service worker to start servicing the
running application immediately instead
of waiting until the next time we get to
this application this will allow us to
keep start fetching and cashing the
newest articles already on the first
time alright so we'll go back to our
application will refresh here make sure
that we have a new service worker up and
running we can go in and check in our
cache tab here that everything that we
defined in that static array actually
did get cached now that we have stuff in
the cache let's go back to our manifest
tab here and see if we're able to add
this to the home screen it turns out
that we're still not able to do add this
to our home screen because it's still
not working offline the way the browser
knows that it's not working offline is
because even though we did put stuff
into the cache we haven't used any of
that stuff so we still need to prove to
the browser that we work offline the way
we do that is by listening for yet
another event so we'll add a listener
for the fetch event now this listener
will get essentially this listener will
intercept any fetch request going from
our application out to the network so
this will allow us to handle these
anyway we want to essentially what I'm
doing here is I'm differentiating on
traffic based on where it's going so if
we're fetching something from our own
application so that would be any of
these static resources we want to check
first if it's in our cache and return
that and if not then we could go to the
network if we're fetching news though
what we want to do is we want to fetch
the latest news first and then only if
we're unable to do that because we're
offline or whatever then we want to see
if we might have an older version in our
cache so the cache first strategy would
look something like this
so first of all we will open up the same
cache that we had from before
we will then call cache stop match see
if there's something in our cache that
matches this request if there is we'll
return that if not we will fall back on
the network the network first strategy
will look a little bit different but it
should be pretty straightforward as well
so what we do here is we will open up
the same cache but will first try to see
if we are able to fetch that from the
network if we are able to fetch it from
the network we will put that version
into the cache so we'll put a clone of
it just because we're only able to read
a response once so that way we can put
one version into the cache and then
return the other one if any of this
fails so if we're unable to fetch the
latest news we'll fall back on something
that we have in our cache so we'll again
call this cache that match and return
that so let's go to our browser let's
refresh here let's look at the
serviceworker here we have a
serviceworker here just registered we
can go into our cache storage here
verify that we're caching stuff not only
those static assets that we have but
also some stuff from the network
and if we now go into the manifest file
tab here click on add to homescreen it
will actually trigger the add to
homescreen logic we should always also
be able to go to the service worker tab
here and take our application offline
and still be able to refresh and see
that it's working
so hopefully this gave you a good idea
of what it's like to turn an application
into a progressive web application by
adding that manifest file and adding
that Service Worker now normally if
you're building an app for yourself you
probably don't want to use this very
low-level API that I just showed you
there are libraries like workbox that
I'll link in the show notes below that
you can use to kind of simplify this a
whole lot and gives you much more tools
to do things like manage your cache size
and how many how many images you want to
cache or how long you want to keep
something in the cache for alright so
thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed
it I'll see you later